PATRICK MEENAN: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
My name is Patrick Meenan.
I'm part of the Make the Web
Faster team here at Google,
which is actually kind of an
exciting position to be in,
because we get to focus on
the rest of the web.
We don't have to just focus
on Google's properties.
And one of the things I'm going
to talk about today is
where we get an intersection
of something that's really
good for web performance.
But it's also one of the things
that you want to pay
attention to, and there's a
really good reason to pay
attention to it for your
sites, which is the
third-party scripts and what
can happen to your sites as
you integrate them, and good
ways to protect your site when
things happen to them.
So I want to start off with--
this is sort of an
anonymized--
it's a real live page from the
internet, sort of cleaned it
up so you can't recognize
the owner, to use for
the examples here.
And as we go through, I'm going
to talk about a couple
of different pages and
sites and stuff.
These are just examples.
They happen everywhere.
And in particular, I'm going
to be picking on Google a
little bit here as well, because
the issues even happen
with our tags, for example.
But this is what happens when
the page is loading normally.
This is kind of what
it feels like.
It's a pretty average page.
It takes four or five
seconds to load.
So there's a social widget
on the page.
It's got the Google+ button.
It's a little script tag, drop
it in, and voila, you've got
sharing for your site.
And you can spread the content
around the internet.
It's great.
Unfortunately, when the widget
is unavailable--
Google doesn't really go down
very often, but it does go
down in various parts of
the world sometimes.
This happens to everyone.
So yeah, are you still waiting
for the site to load?
Or have gone on and finished
your browsing somewhere else
because you think
the site's down?
So this is actually a
best case scenario.
On Windows, it'll take 20
seconds to timeout before the
browser realizes that
a site or a piece of
content is not available.
On Mac and Linux, you're talking
60 plus seconds.
So that's like complete
absurdity.
The user would never wait that
long for it unless they're on
a mobile phone, and they're
expecting not to be able to
access content.
And all of that is because the
one line of code where they
injected the script.
So the way browsers work, as
a browser is evaluating the
content in your HTML, it
does it from top to
bottom in your HTML.
There's some preprocessors
that'll look for anything that
looks like an URL, and it'll
try and fetch it for you.
But as soon as it hits a script
tag, the browser needs
to execute everything inside
of the script tag before it
can go on and do anything
else with the DOM.
And in this case, since the
script tag is actually
referring to an external piece
of content, the browser needs
to fetch that external piece
of content, finish fetching
it, and then execute
it before it can do
anything else in the page.
So the more common way to do it
or the more performant way
to do it and to avoid it is to
use an async script tag.
It's somewhat uglier, which is
why especially product people
and designers don't like it when
we try and put these up
for our documentation,
in particular.
It's like, but that's so
much uglier than the
other script tag.
But yeah, but it doesn't
block the page.
And the slides are going to be
made available after the talk.
So don't worry about trying to
record any of the URLs or
anything like that.
We'll have them all available.
And so this is what it's
going to look like.
We've got the normal
site on the left.
We call it SPOF, front-end SPOF,
Single Point of Failure.
And the async version of
the page on the right.
So in the right, the Google+
button is still failing.
But it happened to fail fast.
And actually, the page
even loaded faster.
That's because in the normal
case, the browser still needed
to fetch the +1 JavaScript and
execute it before it could
move beyond the script tag.
With the async version, all it's
executing is injecting a
DOMNode locally.
It doesn't have to
fetch anything.
So even in a good mode, it can
load faster by loading it
asynchronously.
So that's why it's been a
common push from the web
performance community to load
your tags asynchronously for
performance reasons.
But there's really good
reasons for your site
availability as well.
More importantly, your
monitoring systems are going
to tell you nothing's wrong.
Your base page came back fine.
You know, your HTML loaded.
In this case, it loaded in
under 200 milliseconds.
So anything you've got hitting
your server says, hey, my
sites doing fine, no problems.
Your full browser monitoring, if
you're using a product that
loads your site with
a real browser,
your site took longer.
It took 20 seconds to load,
but it didn't fail.
Most of those products usually
have like a 60-second timeout.
So if you have thresholds set to
tell you when it's slower,
and on the off chance that you
actually have alarming tied to
that, you would have
been notified.
But otherwise, in most cases,
you wouldn't know until the
next day or whenever you go and
look at your performance
data for the site.
And even your analytics.
Usually, you'll put your
analytics tags way up at the
top of the page because
you want to count
every single page view.
And it's usually loaded
asynchronously.
So your analytics, your page
view counts, all of that
would've looked fine.
And even your real user.
Let's say, you're fringe,
cutting edge, and you've got
real user monitoring for your
page load performance in
place, where you've got
JavaScript beacons.
And you're looking at
window.performance, and you're
reporting the load times
of your pages
back to your server.
Well, 99.9% of those scripts
wait until onload before they
report any data because they
want to report how long it
took for the page to load.
They don't have any
timeouts in it.
They just wait for
the onload event.
Never happened, because
the user bailed.
That one page--
so I told you I pulled a page
from the wild, and this was
just a random page I pulled
from the wild--
has all of these blocking
scripts up at the top of it.
So if any one of those
third-party providers go down,
that's the experience you get
when you're looking at it.
So pulling from the HTTP
archive, it's a project that
right now we're up
to 200,000 URLs.
We scan twice a month from the
Alexa top million, and we're
trying to scale it
up to a million.
But even as we scale up the
number of domains we crawl,
the number of domains
on each page, you're
looking at 12, 13 domains.
So it's not uncommon, and it's
becoming more and more popular
to pull in more and more
third-party content that you
don't control and lots of it.
So you're going, OK, well, my
boss is going to yell at me,
because he's browsing the site
or his friend's browsing the
site, and it's not
working, right?
But not necessarily, because
it's not always 100%.
Somewhere in the world, well,
you know, social sites are
really prone to being blocked
by governments.
These three platforms, Twitter,
Facebook, and
Google+, all of those are
blocked in various parts of
the world 100% of the time.
So just think about
it for a minute.
You may not be Facebook.
You're just a site that happened
to put a Facebook
widget on your page or a Google+
button on your page.
And you're actually trying to
target a global audience.
But because of that one little
button, your page is not
available in big parts of the
world if you're not doing it
asynchronously.
HTTPS as well in certain parts
of the world, depending on the
day of the week,
may be blocked.
So even locally in the US,
enterprises have all sorts of
weird policies in place.
I bumped into a guy.
At one point, I was
loading jQuery.
So I run a public site called
WebPagetest.org.
And we were using jQuery from
Google's AJAX API CDN.
And one of the corporate
policies that one of the users
had in place, they decided they
didn't want any of their
users using Google Search,
because they wanted their
users focused on work
all of the time.
So they blocked everything
Google, which included the
jQuery from Google's AJAX CDN.
It's like, oh, good Lord, you're
blocking half of the
internet at that point.
So I wanted to briefly give you
a quick introduction into
what we call a waterfall chart,
if you haven't seen
these before.
Who here has seen a waterfall
chart before?
Excellent.
I like this audience.
OK, so really quickly, each
line in the waterfall is a
single request that the
browser is making out.
This one, in particular,
came from WebPagetest.
But the main thing to pay
attention to is the first line
in the waterfall we usually
refer to as the back-end.
That's the server call that
generated the HTML.
The rest of it we refer to as
the front-end, which is
everything that the browser
decides to pull in based on
the HTML that you served it.
And we have a couple
of vertical lines.
One of the interesting ones is
the green one, which is the
first paint that the
browser makes.
But as you can tell, most of
the content, most of the
requests that go out are for the
front-end, which is why we
call the scripts a front-end
single point of failure.
So happy user.
We go through all sorts of
insane gyrations to make
servers highly available,
especially for the back-end.
We have redundant DNS servers,
globally distributed.
And by we, I mean, everybody,
not Google.
This is pretty much every
company I've ever worked with
that works at any scale.
And even with the cloud these
days, anyone does this.
You've got redundant DNS servers
to make sure that the
user can always resolve
your host name.
You've got load balancers in
front of your servers to make
sure that it's always
available.
You've got multiple app
servers that the load
balancers can talk to.
So that if any of those go down,
you can still serve the
content to the users.
And there is no user-perceived
failures.
You've got redundant databases,
shards, replicats,
all of that, just to make sure
that the user always gets
their HTML.
That's great.
But that's all for that first
line in the waterfall, right?
You're hoping that everyone
does all of that for every
other request.
But what we really want to do
is take that same redundancy
that you do for the back-end
to make sure that it always
gets delivered and put the
same protections in your
front-end code.
So that's pretty much where
we're talking about async.
So the async snippet, we got a
little peek at it earlier.
Google Analytics was sort of
one of the big ones that
worked out the different
browsers and the different
browser behaviors and
what works well
across all of the browsers.
And this one pretty much
ends up working well.
As you create a dynamic script
element, you inject it before
the first script element
on the DOM.
You can be guaranteed there
will always be a script
element on the DOM because
you're injecting it from
within a script element.
So worst case, it's the one
you're injecting in it.
And you insert it.
And none of the browsers will
block based on that insertion.
They will all treat that
as an async snippet.
And they'll go ahead
and execute it, and
they'll just fetch it.
This works really well when
there are no dependencies.
You don't care when
the code executes.
Whenever the browser happens to
land the code, it runs it.
And don't have any other code.
Expect that that code
will be there at any
specific point in time.
One of the other common
patterns, Steve Souders in
particular, High Performing Web
Sites book, really popular
in the web performance
community.
And he came from Yahoo on the
Exceptional Performance team.
One of the patterns is to just
move all of your scripts to
the bottom of the DOM.
They'll still block.
But they won't block anything
that the user sees.
They'll block any other
content that
comes behind them.
So if they're right at the
bottom of the body of the
page, all they're really
blocking is the code.
This is really easy
to implement.
A little harder if you have a
whole lot of inline scripts
sprinkled throughout your page,
but it lets you keep the
dependency chains, and you can
just move everything down to
the bottom.
I will say really quickly
because I'm sure there will be
questions, well, what about
the HTML5 async tag?
Why don't we just use that?
That's great.
And it actually performs a lot
better than even the async
script, where you inject it
because the browser's
pre-fetchers can see
that as an URL.
And no matter where it happens
on the page, they'll go ahead,
and they'll predict that you'll
need that, and they'll
be able to find it.
They can't find the script URL
that you're going to inject by
a JavaScript.
The big problem with the async
tag is none of the IE versions
in the field right
now support it.
And you end up with a blocking
script tag for all of IE.
So you're still--
at least today unless you're
doing mobile only, you're
still a lot better using a
dynamically injected script
than putting an async
tag on a script tag.
One of the other things, so to
avoid the HTTPS issue or
forcing all of your users
to use HTTPS is use
protocol-relative URLs.
They work in all browsers.
IE has a problem with
protocol-relative URLs with CSS.
It'll load it twice
for some reason.
But it'll work perfectly
fine with JavaScript.
So if you're sharing any code
that you want people to embed,
try and do it with
protocol-relative URLs instead
of forcing HTTPS.
The one thing is users
may get confused.
They'll be like, but where's
the HTTP in front of it?
So we've got a little education
to do there.
But it's a good way to do it
in a protocol-neutral way.
Finally, if you've got really
complex dependency chains and
you still want to do things
asynchronously, there are a
ton of loaders out there.
Modernizr includes one as well,
which is a fairly good
way to do it if you're already
depending on Modernizr.
But there are also standalone
async loaders.
And what they let you do is they
let you chain together
and explicitly state the
dependency chain of resources.
So in this case, it's saying,
hey, load jQuery.
And when you're done loading
jQuery, load this other
library that needed jQuery.
Or you can even execute inline
script directly there, and you
just chain them together
in a long series.
You can do pretty cool things,
somewhat more complex even,
where you load jQuery
from one place.
In this case, the Google
AJAX libraries.
But if that fails, you can load
it from a local copy.
And then, when you're finally
done with that chain, go ahead
and load the other library
that needed jQuery.
This definitely requires a lot
more work, and building it
into your actual system for
building your apps.
But if you've got complex
dependency chains in your
code, this is a really good way
to do it asynchronously.
Because the main problem when
you're doing the async, you
basically need to attach an
onload handler to your script
that you injected to know when
it finished loading before you
can execute the code that
depends on that, which is why
the loaders are really
helpful.
So we're all set, right?
We can load asynchronously.
Well, not quite.
Async tags on pretty much
all browsers will
block the onload event.
And you'll actually see, so IE
9 and below doesn't, and some
of the older browsers.
But they're all moving towards
blocking because the HTML5
spec explicitly calls for
injected script to block the
onload event.
If you follow Stoyan
Stefanov at all--
phpied.com--
he blogged today about a
technique where you can avoid
onload blocking.
If you put the script into an
iframe and you inject the URL
for the iframe after you've
injected the iframe into the
DOM, it gets orders of magnitude
more complicated.
So just be aware that even if
you're loading the scripts
asynchronously, one of these
things being down can still
block your onload.
Not so much of a big deal for
the user experience as long as
you don't have anything critical
attached to onload.
What you need to be careful of
and not assume is don't assume
your onload will run.
So be careful, set timeouts.
If you're progressively
enhancing the UI with anything
menu-wise, or form validation,
or anything like that, try and
attach it in a logical fashion
that makes sense just from the
way the page loads, not
necessarily trying to push it
back after onload.
Because you could get into a
state where the user sees the
page, but then can't interact
with it for 20 seconds.
And it's not a whole
lot better.
So as an industry.
And this is where I took 20
minutes, and I just browsed
the web randomly.
So nothing against
these companies.
This is just to show you sort of
how widespread the issue is
and how common it is.
And if you think it's sort of,
well, you know, there's only
two or three small sites that
have this problem out there.
Oh, actually, we're not
in the sites yet.
These are the actual scripts
that we share with you.
So Google, when we launched the
+1 button-- and it's one
of the reasons I used it as an
example-- we actually launched
it as a blocking script.
It's no longer a blocking
script.
The internet was kind enough
to call us out on it,
especially since we pushed
performance so well.
And we got it fixed
really quickly.
Unfortunately, whenever you
launch something, everyone
integrates it as soon
as you launch it.
They don't go back and fix it.
So there's a whole lot of
blocking Google +1 button
scripts out there as well.
And it's really hard to be
consistent and not have
blocking scripts seep their way
into your documentation.
So you'll notice on the right
side, the Google +1 Badge, it
can actually work perfectly fine
asynchronously, and it'll
be fixed any day now.
But the documentation on the
site has samples that use a
blocking script tag.
So it's really easy for this
to regress and to just keep
finding its way into
the documentation.
And as developers, we
copy and paste.
So if it's in the documentation,
that's what's
ending up on people's sites.
But every one of these buttons,
even if they're in
the async column, when they
launched, they were blocking.
So you can expect that out in
the field the vast majority of
the implementations are actually
blocking tags.
Pinterest is an interesting
one.
Their example is blocking, but
their documentation says to
insert it right at the
end of the body.
The problem with that
is there's a lot of
CMS systems out there.
And sometimes it's easier to
just attach code, say, to a
post, for example, rather than
trying to figure out a way to
just inject it once
at the end.
And you end up getting it right
in the middle anyway.
So just be aware of that if
you're pushing any scripts.
Code libraries.
This is a lot harder.
So these, the widgets, the
social buttons and stuff, have
no dependencies whatsoever.
They're perfect candidates
for async.
You drop a piece of code on
your page, and voila, a
button shows up.
Code libraries, on the other
hand, by definition, pretty
much, have dependency chains.
And getting them to load, that's
where you've got to use
the loaders and everything
else, and
it's a lot more complex.
The samples for every code
library I have ever seen have
you loading the code library
blocking in the head.
It wouldn't be so bad if they
said, eh, a bunch of HTML here
and then closing tag body
down at the bottom.
But it's cleaner.
It's easier for the developer to
read if you see, load code
library, load code library UI,
load plug-in whatever, and
then run code.
The problem is, once again,
we're creatures of copy and
paste, and that's what you end
up seeing on all the websites.
So definitely watch
out for these.
If you don't want to go the
loader route, move them to the
bottom of the page at least,
get them out of
the way of the content.
There may be a couple of cases
where your UI depends on the
JavaScript.
Best if you don't, progressive
enhancement, and all that.
But if you do, try and
move it out of the
way as much as possible.
Ad providers.
So ads, I don't know how many
of you remember way back in
the day, all of what?
About a year ago, where you'd
load a website, and all you
would see is a header
at the top.
And finally an ad would
populate, and then the rest of
the content would go.
And you'd go, oh, man, those
ads are slowing down
everything.
Things are actually
a lot better now.
The ad providers, the calling
chain, and the complexity of
loading an ad hasn't gotten
a lot better.
But they have gotten
out of your way.
Doubleclick was the
first, I believe.
I'm not sure if they're still
the only one with a fully
async tag that you can
inject on your pages.
So even loading the script that
loads the Doubleclick ads
doesn't get in the
way of anything.
Adsense, maybe a year
ago, the script
itself is still blocking.
But everything after the script
that loads is done in
an iframe, and it's completely
asynchronous.
And the Adsense script is so
pervasive that odds are it's
in everyone's cache
by the time they
hit your page anyway.
The main reason they did that
was they could get 100%
penetration on async ads if they
could push out and not
change how the script
is embedded.
And I'm not sure about
other ad providers.
But if you're using another ad
provider, a lot of them do
have async implementations.
If they don't, at least
if they don't have it
documented, ask them.
A lot of them have
iframe solutions.
You have to be a little careful
just blindly taking
the iframe implementation,
which would be async.
The problem with those are they
usually don't do as good
targeting as if you use a
JavaScript implementation.
So be a little careful just
doing it blindly.
So when you've found a
third-party single point of
failure and you want to see
what it looks like when it
happens, well, back in the day
also, we used to route
everything to localhost if we
wanted to see it fail, because
it wouldn't respond
to the requests.
It would just fail.
The problem is it fails
right away.
It's right there on your
local machine.
So that's not how
sites go down.
That's not how third
parties go down.
What they do is they timeout.
So you need a black hole.
And this was a really difficult
server to set
up, to scale it.
I can guarantee, it will never,
ever respond to anything.
So feel free to use it.
You can put in your
host's file.
Point third-party domains
to that IP address or to
blackhole.webpagetest.org if
you want to see what the
experience is like loading.
You won't actually need
to do it manually.
We've got solutions in
place to help you.
On the WebPagetest--
and I'll do a demo towards the
end with doing this-- you can
also force third-party domains
to point to the black hole, so
you can capture waterfalls,
or video, or see what the
experience is without
having to muck with
your local host file.
And you can share it.
The sharing is particularly
important if you want to show
someone, yes, we really
do have a problem.
And this is what it looks
like when X goes down.
But there's a sample
script in there.
And like I said, the slides
will also be shared.
And I wanted to introduce
you to SPOF-O-Matic.
It's in the Chrome Web Store.
It's something I created for
this presentation, largely.
But I've been browsing the
web for it for the
last couple of weeks.
It's kind of entertaining
and kind of scary.
What it does is it installs, and
it gives you a little gray
circle when everything's happy
and nothing's happening.
There's no third-party single
points of failure on the site.
If it detects any likely
third-party single points of
failure, it'll give you a big
warning icon and tell you how
many were detected
on the page.
And it does us all passively
while you browse.
You don't have to click
to turn anything on.
And then when you click on it,
it'll give you a list of the
different things that were
detected as well as how much
of the page content it blocks.
So something way down at the
bottom of the page, like in
this case the tracer down
at the bottom of the
page, blocks nothing.
But everything up at the top,
the jQuery, Optimizely, even
the +1 button up at the
top, block a fair
amount of page content.
So those are the ones that you
want to be careful of.
It's really ultra-conservative
in its detection.
So it's less likely that you'll
get false positives.
You're more likely to get false
negatives when you're browsing.
And if you get tired,
there is a site.
You know, hey, I know this
is a third party.
I'm expecting it to be a third
party, and it's just too much
of a pain to change it.
Or this isn't really
a third party.
You can whitelist the domains
directly from the UI so it
stops warning you about it.
And you can clear the whitelist
or edit it.
One of the cool things that you
can do is you can turn it
into resource blocking mode if
you click the enable button up
at the top.
And it will automatically route
the third-party domains
it detects to the black
hole for you.
So you can browse the web as
if third-party domains were
down and see what the
experience is.
And when it's enabled, you'll
get a little black hole up at
the top of the screen.
By the way, if no one's ever
seen any of my UIs, I should
not be allowed anywhere
near end user UI.
So that's why you get
circles for icons.
And so while you're browsing the
web, when it kicks in, and
when it blocks third-party
content, you'll get a little
stop sign inside of
the black hole.
And I don't recommend running
in this mode for a long time
unless you're really just
trying to quit the web,
because you're just going to
stare at a whole lot of blank
screens as you're browsing,
a whole lot of them.
And this is where we get to see
how many of those you'll
actually be staring at.
So this is where if I took about
20 minutes, didn't spend
a whole lot of time.
And I was like, hey, let's see
how pervasive the problem is.
Let's see if I can find enough
to populate the deck with to
let people see.
So new sites.
CNN, the main page is
perfectly fine.
And once again, nothing against
these developers.
They took the snippets that
everyone gave them.
They copied and pasted
it into their sites.
And these are just a really
rough sample.
This is everywhere.
But the CNN main page is
perfectly fine and loads
everything asynchronously.
But when you get down to the
article page, there are a
couple of different scripts that
it's loading blocking.
And you'll generally see that
repeated because they want
people sharing the articles.
So you'll see more of the
social buttons, and the
sharing widgets, and that kind
of thing on the low-level
content, not necessarily on
the front page of sites.
So be careful testing
just the front page.
The Today Show's main page has
a fair number, including a
bunch of polls and some
Typekit font stuff.
ABC News's main page has a
blocking Facebook button.
So news sites, they share
a lot of content.
It's not unexpected.
Blog content sites, once again,
same sort of thing.
They want you sharing
the content.
The Verge pulls a whole bunch
of jQuery from Google APIs
right up at the top of the
page, which is fine.
Pulling from Google APIs
is a good pattern,
because it's shared.
It tends to be in
people's caches.
Just try and move it down to the
bottom of page on the odd
chance that it's down or
it's blocked somewhere.
And I'm not entirely sure
what crowd control is.
But it sounds like it's a
user-targeting type thing.
Same goes for a lot of
the other blogs.
Oh, the last one, definitely
something I
want to talk about.
CNET is pulling in the HTML5
shim code directly from the
trunk of Google Code.
That's brave.
[LAUGHTER]
PATRICK MEENAN: So I hope they
personally know everyone that
has commit access to that.
But from a performance
perspective, you also want to
be really careful.
Both GitHub and Google Code
are not designed to serve
static content to end users.
They're not a CDN.
They don't have caching headers
on the resources.
They're not designed to
be performant for
serving static content.
So don't encourage users to pull
your code directly from--
even if it's from a stable
branch, don't recommend
pulling code directly from
the code repositories.
Definitely don't recommend
people to pull it from the
trunk on production pages.
Politicians.
Yay, I'm from DC.
So I can't help but look and
see, hey, is it more of a
Democrat or a Republican
problem?
It's equal opportunity.
And the White House as well.
So all of these are blocking
scripts up at the top of their
respective pages.
E-Commerce I was a little more
surprised about, because it's
not really content.
But then when I thought about
a little more it's like, OK,
well, maybe they want people
sharing the product pages.
Or I guess in the case of
Bazaarvoice, the reviews,
they're pulling reviews
in from a third party.
But all of these are blocking
up at the top of the pages.
So even the Pinterest button,
for example, on Newegg's
product page isn't following the
pattern of being down at
the bottom of the body.
So people don't do what you
ask them to do in case you
were wondering.
So in these cases, the product
pages, in particular, you'll
go ahead, like Best Buy, you'll
be browsing around.
You'll find the category of
things you want to look at.
And then you'll go to
click onto a product
and try and buy it.
And at that point, you get
a completely blank page.
So it's good that you can
see what they offer.
It kind of sucks that
you can't buy.
So coming out of here--
and we're not done yet, but I
definitely want what you guys
to take away is if you're
creating the next big social
media company and you create a
widget that you want everyone
to use, please, don't
ever, ever
provide a blocking snippet.
Don't let it seep into your
documentation, even for a
couple of minutes,
because that's
what people will implement.
All of your examples, no matter
where it is in your
documentation, make
them asynchronous.
The documentation for Google's
JS API is a really good
example of that.
Most of our documentation has
a blocking script example
because it's the cleanest, and
it's sort of the easiest to
understand.
But if you dig really deep into
the documentation, you
can actually find that it
supports callbacks and a
completely async method of
loading even the JS API code,
so another thing we're working
on cleaning up.
HTTPS, try not to force it
if it's not required.
Remember, you're trying
to get other people
to adopt your code.
So even if you want things in
the internet to be as secure
as possible--
yadda, yadda, yadda--
don't try and push all of that
on the sites that are
embedding your code.
It would be really great if you
allowed sites to self-host
anything that was absolutely
critical to them
being able to load.
If you're a site owner building
a site, don't ever,
ever load anything that's
provided by a third party
synchronously unless you
absolutely trust and depend
and are willing to bet your
site availability on their
availability and all of
their availability.
No one is ever up 100%.
I'll tell you that now.
Even Google is never up 100%.
You see, every now and
then, Gmail outages.
Very, very rarely, but
nobody is up 100%.
And once you start stacking
those, if you have three or
four external dependencies,
you're availability starts
going down.
Be careful relying on onload.
We talked about this
a little bit.
Don't expect it to happen.
Have timeouts, especially your
performance timing scripts,
for example.
Have it timeout something less
aggressive than 20 seconds
that you can fire and say,
hey, it didn't happen.
You're monitoring, make sure
you have really aggressive
timeouts there as well.
It kind of sucks to
get false alarms.
You know, I've been
in this world.
We get production pages.
We're monitoring.
They have ads on them.
They vary all over the place.
The ops teams don't like getting
woken up in the middle
of the night because an ad
pushed out the load time.
Unfortunately, if you keep the
timeouts really conservative,
you may never know when you have
a script blocking your
page from loading.
And in your analytics, if you
have it available, make sure
you take a look at the regions
and track your
page failures by region.
This is where you really want
the real user monitoring.
Because odds are, you aren't
going to be able to have
synthetic tests.
Your monitoring system's testing
from every network in
every country around
the world.
And your best way to dig in to
those failures is to look at
your analytics and look at your
failures by region from
your beacons on your pages
to see what's going on.
So now we're going to kick over
and play a little bit
with SPOF-O-Matic.
So here we have it up here.
We'll browse around
a little bit.
So Newegg's main page, it's
fine, still nice and gray.
Let's see, I need
a new plasma TV.
All right, and here, we
get the warning icon.
Of course, that doesn't
actually zoom
in the Chrome UI.
And we can see the Pinterest
button, for example, is
blocking 99% of the page.
We'll go ahead and turn on
resource blocking, so we can
experience the fun.
Oh, I liked this one, SANS,
which is telling you the
availability of the internet,
vulnerabilities, things like that.
[LAUGHTER]
PATRICK MEENAN: Yay,
we see their logo.
At least it's not a completely
blank page.
So that's the other thing
to be aware of.
It doesn't block 100% of the
page all of the time.
It's not always a completely
blank screen.
It depends on where the script
tag is on the page.
Hey, there we go.
Network security.
So in this case, the search box
was actually loaded by a
blocking script.
So you got to see the header and
everything up until it hit
the script to populate
the search box.
I guess Best Buy since I used
them as an example earlier.
We'll browse around.
Oh, well, that didn't
take too long.
OK, so you'll stare at a blank
screen there for a while.
Like I said, you probably don't
want to browse around
for too long with it in blocking
mode because you're
going to get a lot of this.
And it gets really tiring to
browse the internet like this.
But I at least enjoy leaving it
enabled in detection mode
as I browse around and just look
up every now and then up
at the top corner and
see how often the
warning icon comes up.
And it's a pretty safe bet, 80
plus percent of the sites that
i browse on any given day all
have some form of blocking
scripts on their page that
they don't control.
And actually, before I hop over,
in a second I'm going to
show you how to create.
So all of the videos that I
showed you earlier that showed
the experience were created
in WebPagetest.
I'm going to show you how
to create one of those.
So if you're going to be sharing
with someone, you can
give them a video.
Executives seem to respond
really well
to seeing the videos.
So if you need to sell someone
on it, that's a really good
way to do it.
They don't tend to understand
waterfalls
or understand SPOFs.
But before that, did anyone
have a site that
they wanted to try?
Please, safe for work.
AUDIENCE: Blazingcloud.net.
PATRICK MEENAN:
Blazingcloud.net.
[TYPING]
PATRICK MEENAN: Well, looking
good, all gray.
Now, let's see the blog,
though, where they have
content that they like-- oh!
[LAUGHING]
PATRICK MEENAN: That's
actually not too bad.
It's loading jQuery.
It is loading up at the top.
But let's see about a specific
article page.
No, it's still jQuery.
I don't see any social sharing
buttons either.
So that's probably why the
blog is relatively safe.
Yeah, right up here.
AUDIENCE: Shutterfly.com.
PATRICK MEENAN: Sorry,
can you speak up?
AUDIENCE: Shutterfly.com.
PATRICK MEENAN: Shutterfly.com.
[TYPING]
PATRICK MEENAN: Also looks
good, although--
oh, I was going to say I don't
think I even remember.
I used to have a Shutterfly
account.
But it's been a little while.
Take a tour.
Oh, no, that looks like
it's a video.
Store.
Oh, here we go.
So once again, it's
not too bad.
So they turn yellow when they're
down below 50% of the
page or so that's blocked
in this case, although--
so one of them is the ad.
Quantserve is a tracking
pixel, I believe.
Having anything that's not
user facing as a blocking
script is also probably
something you want to
completely avoid, especially
anything that's like user
behavioral tracking and stuff
that the users don't see.
It's not for the users.
You're doing it for you.
Try and get it out of the
way as much as possible.
You can still have it up at the
top of the page, just do
it asynchronously so it doesn't
block anything.
And then we'll hop back here
and browse a little more
towards the end if
we've got time.
But I wanted to show,
really quickly.
So this is a WebPagetest
load of--
oh, OK, so this is sort of the
cross between the performance
world and the availability
and why it's important.
We tend to like waterfalls that
do a lot of this and are
more vertical and a lot less
of this where they start to
get horizontal.
And when they start to get
horizontal, that's where you
have a series of things
that are blocking.
And in this case, it's actually
the Google APIs.
Not that one.
Here, the JS API that then
creates a dependency chain and
loads things serially that's
a blocking tag.
It document writes all
sorts of patterns you
want to try and avoid.
But asynchronously, it would
have shaved 3 seconds off of
the page load in this case just
by loading that script
asynchronously.
And we get the other benefits
of not blocking.
AUDIENCE: You said there's
something in the documentation
code, JS API asynchronously?
PATRICK MEENAN: In the JS
API, look for callback.
It's actually a query pram that
you can pass to JS API.
Callback, and you can
pass it a function.
And as soon as it loads, it'll
actually call your function to
let you know it's loaded.
And then you can do whatever
you depended on
JS API being loaded.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PATRICK MEENAN: Yes.
I was really happy
when I saw it.
So you don't even need
a third-party loader.
It has it built in.
It's just not promoted
right now in the UI.
So this is WebPagetest.
If you haven't tried it,
I highly recommend it.
Not just because I created it,
but we use it a lot when we're
doing performance analysis.
You drop in an URL, and you
get a waterfall back.
You can record video.
But what you do is in here,
you'll do setDNS.
So there's a whole bunch of
options you have in the UI.
You can capture TCP dumps
and DevTools Timelines,
and things like that.
The script tab is where we put
the really crazy advanced
features that we couldn't figure
out how to create UI
buttons for.
And I did mention how I suck
at UIs, so that's why
everything's a tab and
a radio button.
[TYPING]
PATRICK MEENAN: So if you want
to block Facebook, for
example, you do setDNSName,
connect facebook.net, and
point that to black hole.
[TYPING]
PATRICK MEENAN: And then tell it
to navigate to the page you
want to test.
You probably want to record
video because you're going to
want to create a video to show
people what it looks like.
And then say, this is
what it looks like
when Facebook is down.
And once again, not picking on
Facebook here, it just happens
to be an easy one.
We all have this problem.
All right, just get rid of
the ads for a second.
Yes.
By the way, you now know my
super secret query pram,
bare=1, to get rid of the ads
when you're taking screenshots
and things like that.
So we'll go ahead and let
that finish running.
I did run some examples
before.
So what you want to do when
you want to create a
side-by-side video,
for example.
So recording video for any
one page is great.
But what you really want to do
is be able to do the side by
side and show, this is what
it's like normally.
This is what it's
like super fast.
And this is what it's like when
X is down or some of the
other reasons we do it.
This is what it's like
when we block ads.
So you can see the impact that
ads have on the performance.
If you go into your test history
and select the ones
you want to compare, you can
just check the ones you want
to compare.
Click the Compare button.
And you'll get a filmstrip of
what both of them look like
when they're loading.
You can sort of scroll
and play with it.
And way out here somewhere,
you get 20 seconds.
And you can also
create a video.
That will be available
shortly.
Magic cooking show.
We have one we already did.
And all of these URLs,
they're permanent.
They're shareable.
We keep the data forever.
So you can share the filmstrips,
the raw test
results, the videos.
You can also download the raw
video, if you want to embed it
in anything.
Generally, in the web
performance world, if you see
any videos that look like
this, that have multiple
videos side by side with the
little timer going below it,
they came from WebPagetest.
But this works really well when
you're trying to sell
executives on why it matters.
And even on the performance side
of things, they respond
very well to video.
It's like, well, this is what
it used to look like.
This is what it looks
like now.
See how much faster it is?
Pay us more to do this.
Oh, wow, it didn't
work at all.
Let me try it with Chrome.
So have a whole bunch of
different browsers you can use
to select for doing
your testing.
The Chrome ones, you can
actually record a DevTools
Timeline as well, if you want
all sorts of trace information
for debugging.
While those are running, anyone
else want to experiment
with their site and
offer it up?
Or someone else's site
and offer it up
for everyone to see?
AUDIENCE: Developers.google.com.
PATRICK MEENAN: What was
that developers--
So yes, my keyboard has a
problem with repeating O's for
some reason, which is
really difficult
when you work at Google.
[LAUGHTER]
PATRICK MEENAN: So nothing
loaded from third parties.
However, the waterfall that I
used earlier, you'll notice up
here, is for
developers.google.com.
So the JS API is something we're
working on, even on the
Developers page to get it out
of the way and make it
significantly faster.
And it's also got a little
problem with
the first byte time.
3 seconds is kind of obscene.
So we're also looking at that.
We tend to prefer first byte
times in the 100 millisecond
range or so.
OK, so here's the Business
Insider test.
Yeah, so when we're looking at
waterfalls, usually if it
doesn't fit above the fold,
that's a lot of resources.
So yeah, whenever I'm working on
web performance stuff, get
a lot of stuff just
looking from the
thumbnail of the waterfall.
How big it is It?
What does it look like as
far as the shape of
the waterfall goes?
The yellow lines are either
redirects or, in the case of a
repeat view, 304s,
Not Modified.
There, it just finished.
If you see any red lines,
those are worse.
Those are 404s, that
kind of thing.
It looks like they
did pretty well.
Maybe this gap way
down here at the
bottom of the waterfall.
Yeah, so the onload got pushed
out to 24 seconds when
Facebook was blocked.
But as you can tell, the user
experience wasn't bad.
Yeah, so the UI showed up
really quickly, well,
relatively quickly.
And it didn't block the
user experience.
Oh, one other thing I can show
you guys while I'm here.
If you're looking at a single
test, you get a
waterfall down below it.
And this red line will
track with the
left edge of the filmstrip.
Because we've got the Start
Render and we've always had
the green Start Render line.
But if you want to see what
caused the actual content--
and it looks like in this case,
most of the content
populated anyway--
but you can figure out what
was blocking the UI from
showing up.
So that was the live portion
of our show.
I think we can kick into any
questions and answers.
I'll tweet out the link and
put it up on Google+.
And I think as part of the show,
we're also going to make
it available.
So any questions?
Wow, you're an easy crowd.
All right, well, thank you.
If you want to hit me up for
anything one on one, I'll hang
around up here for
a couple minutes.
If the next people come in,
we can talk outside in the
hallway or something
like that.
All right, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]